hey crazies I don't think we've done
enough cosmology videos yet there's
still one big question we need to answer
how do we know the universe is expanding
well we've got a lot of data to back up
that claim the plumb telescope really
came through for us but the most famous
is probably the redshift of light
what's a redshift it's a shift in
wavelength toward the wavelength all
right the things we measure about waves
are kind of unusual so let's start with
a quick review waves have two basic
properties wavelength which is the
length of a complete cycle measured with
a ruler in frequency which is how often
Peaks pass one spots these two
properties combine to give you a speed
but how quickly a wave moves really only
depends on the stuff that's doing the
wave for light that's the
electromagnetic field I'm doing this
because you know it's everywhere anyway
since the fundamental properties of the
electromagnetic field never change
neither does the speed of light that
means we can draw something like this
the visible spectrum all the colors that
can be matched with a single wavelength
of light but since the speed of light
never changes we can also match them
with the frequencies of light
under some conditions the color of light
can actually change if it shifts toward
the blue end of the spectrum we say it's
Lu shifted if it shifts toward the red
end we say it red shifted it's that
simple we keep the same concept of
shifting when we write it mathematically
since the light is emitted with a
certain wavelength we expect it to be
received or observed with the same
wavelength in other words we expect this
ratio to be equal to one but sometimes
it's not if not we say a red shift isn't
added the Doppler effect is one way
light can change color and it's
something you're familiar with
but what's out
listen to the sound of this engine as
the car approaches the frequency is
higher than it should be
but once it passes and is moving away
the frequency is lower than it should be
the same kind of thing happens with the
light from the car but it's harder to
notice if you relate the wavelength to
the car speed you can see the problem
since light is so fast this ratio is
roughly 1 for any normal car speed our
eyes aren't that sensitive these two
squares are different colors but how
many of you can actually tell I
certainly can't after playing around
with a few wavelengths - red green blue
converters I found I can tell the
difference between one nanometer in
color just barely but I can do it to see
even that must change with a car it
would have to be going at about a
million miles per hour luckily we have
better tools than our eyes for detecting
this when it comes to stars cosmological
redshift not caused by the doctor of X I
know there's a method to my madness okay
as annoying as he is nerd clone is
usually right and this is no exception I
sure AM besides the Doppler effect if
there are two other sources of redshift
gravity and the expansion of space light
redshift as it escapes from a source of
gravity this is more apparent when the
gravity is strong like the light emitted
by the accretion disk around the black
hole the expansion of space can also
cause a redshift in the light traveling
through it but that expansion is slow so
the light has to be traveling a long
time for us to notice with the light
coming from stuff close by you get it
mixed up with the other two sources of
redshift like I said in a previous video
yes super clusters we don't see the
expansion on scales any smaller than
that because other forces like gravity
are strong enough to hold things
together in spite of the expansion
my point is the cosmological redshift is
not the result of the galaxies speed
away from us it is not the Doppler
effect you've been lied to it's the
result of space stretching along the
trip when light travels between galactic
super clusters that light gets stretched
as the space it's traveling through
stretches the more time that light
travels the more expansion and
experiences remember that scale factor
from the flower metric the thing that
tells you how big the space
infinitesimal begotten we can actually
write the redshift in terms of that it
compares the scale
factor back then to what it is now the
data shows the further back in time we
look the bigger the redshift meaning
there's more expansion between the
cosmic microwave background is the
oldest light in the universe it was
emitted so long ago that it isn't even
visible light anymore
now it's microwave light that's a
redshift of over a thousand we can even
see how fast the scale factor is
changing which tells us the universe is
expanding faster now than it was in the
past it's accelerating that's another
thing to add to the list of info we get
some light unfortunately to know that
there's even been a redshift we need to
know what color the light was supposed
to be but that's a topic for another
video and don't worry a Thrasher I've
started a list for every time I've said
that
anyway crazy so if you've got any
questions about redshift please ask in
the comments thanks for liking and
sharing this video don't forget to
subscribe if you'd like to keep up with
us a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons like quick ploys who help keep
us going and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
[Music]